6 rebonds soir
merci d'être avec nous ce soir alors
pour la dernière hardy view sur ces 8
c'est vous que je reçois les franchement
ça me va très bien
je suis très heureux d'accueillir
l'homme qui envoient des sms au monde et
des messages dans des bouteilles
alors signe
on sait pas très bien pourquoi
en 1972 gordon soloman vous a surnommé
sting le dard est ce parce que vous
portiez sur scène un pull avec des rires
jaunes et noirs ou est ce que c'est
votre sexe donc il était question le
dard
en fait c'est le tard d'une abeille en
même temps je sais les cours que je
pense
animal est un petit bois
voilà exactement alors je vous parle de
ça parce que je vous ai reçue pour la
première fois dans l'une de mes
émissions il ya exactement 15 ans
presque jour pour jour vous m'aviez dit
que vous aimiez le sexe et vous m'aviez
dit aussi que si que s'il vous restait
24 heures à vivre avant la bombe
atomique vous feriez l'amour pendant 24
heures
d'accord
qu'est ce que vous croyez vous
alors sting
alias gordon matthew thomas sumner fils
de m stoner livreur de lait et de old
boy cowell coiffeuse vous êtes né le 2
octobre 1951 à wall 5 près de newcastle
vous avez donné 3000 concerts vous avez
vendu 130 millions d'albums et vous avez
gagné 17 grammy awards
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors si vous êtes de retour aujourd'hui
avec my songs c'est à dire votre vie en
chansons 15 de vos plus grands tubes
réenregistrer certains remixé en
utilisant les pistes originales tandis
que d'autres sont des enregistrements
complets
alors il ya de nouveaux arrangements et
votre voix a changé elle est allée
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus riches vous
avez plus de texture de voix qu'à
l'époque non
c'est comme un bien un vieux vin rouge
qui gagnent de la texture en
vieillissant ces meilleures histoires à
raconter je crois on écoute tout de
suite le nouvel album de sting
ok
que faire
[Musique]
sma
waka
ouais
[Musique]
à
et voilà
[Applaudissements]
l'avenant toulouse cherche listen to you
son animation jamais mes propres
chansons mais c'est une belle surprise
alors quand on vous demande pourquoi un
album de reprises vous dit ce n'est pas
par un manque d'inspiration
c'est juste drôle de revisiter des
chansons j'ai voulu que mes chansons
sonnent le plus contemporaines possible
au gnouf parce que lorsqu'on enregistre
comme une chanson pour la première fois
lors de le jour même de son écriture ou
dessous le lendemain à chaque fois c'est
comme un premier rendez vous d'amour
s'est passé dans cet excitant mais
lorsqu'on est sorti avec anna ou d'un an
deux ans ou 40 ans on la connaît mieux
cette femme où cette chanson un peu il
fait l'amour disons de manière plus
expérimenté donc la première fois plus
excitantes mais à long terme c'est mieux
est-ce que après se disent que vous
allez faire comme elton john devait
faire un bail au pic de votre votre
vivant
jamais jamais madame da mais quand je
serai mort maïwenn jugées risquées
servons testament le problème c'est
qu'on ne connaît pas la fin évidemment
c'est très compliqué pourtant votre
histoire est très belle quand même celle
d'un fils de newcastle working class
heroes qui devient une star mondiale
c'est un super film quand même non
messieurs non
[Applaudissements]
si j'étais à faire notre vie qu'est-ce
que vous ne referiez pas pareil
du tout
c'est toujours ce que j'ai ressenti un
jeu gendre h accepte mon destin j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance dans ma vie tout ce
qui m'est arrivé je suis reconnaissant
vous dites aujourd'hui il devient
difficile d'être optimiste
c'est vrai que dans les années 80 vous
êtes engagé contre la déforestation de
l'amazonie en compagnie du chef raoni
mais aujourd'hui le brésil a élu un
président qui se moque du droit des
indiens et qui vend la masoni à
l'industrie agroalimentaire
duquel a menacé de le faire et ça c'est
toute façon anticonstitutionnelle serré
à l'encontre de la loi brésilienne d'eau
que doit comme respecter la constitution
du brésil avant de faire ça raoni est
reparti en campagne quand on voit raoni
qui revient faire la tournée des
télévisions est-ce que c'est pas la
preuve que ça va mal au brésil
vous savez le chef raoni c'est un
symbole sauvetage de la forêt un symbole
très très puissant le message il ya 30
ans reste le même aujourd'hui il est
encore plus d'actualité d'ailleurs et
donc je suis très fier de mon ami le
chiffre est alors difficile d'être
optimiste aussi en voyant la montée des
populismes en europe en 2016 vous avez
voté contre le break site vous parler du
brésil en disant fucking nightmare et
des zones rennes mais c'est à côté et ça
continue de l'être d'ailleurs
mais vous savez lui de bonnes choses
dans toute cette histoire c'est qu'il ya
plus de gens qui ont voté aux élections
européennes plus que jamais en grande
bretagne de qian mon sensibilité très
forte au parlement européen le parlement
revient ce sera autre chose enregistré
dans les puits la montée des partis
écologistes en europe est une très bonne
chose ou même titre d'ailleurs que la
porter à 2 de l'extrême droit d'eau que
je suis plutôt optimiste politiquement
alors les gens étaient remontés dites
vous à l'époque du bras exit contre
l'austérité imposée par les
conservateurs et oui ils ont voté en
fait sans connaître vraiment les enjeux
de leur vote
disons que c'est un vote contre le
gouvernement c'était une espèce de
motion de censure pour chasser l'eau
mais le résultat de ce vote c'est que
maintenant on se on se retrouve dans une
situation et c'est de sortir de l'europe
mais je pense pas que c'est ce que les
gens voulaient en fait en réalité ils
voudraient
que s'il y avait un deuxième référendum
je suis sûr que le résultat serait dans
l'autre sens j'espère mais vous croyez
pas beaucoup au référendum vous dit en
parlant des des référendums nord éclair
et mussolini organisé des référendums
des
adhésions alignera encore une stricte
affaire tellement compliqué que de poser
une question sauvette oui ou non c'est
complètement absurde c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça
on a un système parlementaire très bien
développé un grand total et c'est comme
ça que la loi se fait c'est papa
référence
effectivement hitler et mussolini marché
au référendum parce qu'ils étaient
populiste il pouvait tromper le peuple
et ce qui est un peu triste dans tout ça
finalement c'est que la reine
assiste à sa impuissante
bien dans notre reine c'est que même
elle règne même s'ils ne gouverne pas le
symbole du pays mais n'a pas de pouvoir
alors contrairement aux états unis le
roi des états unis c'était notre homme
et il a le pouvoir
comment va la reine de votre vitre
distillats
c'est redknapp elle est à new york en ce
moment elle travaille très dur je suis
dit que je peux prendre ma retraite le
temps que celle du canada alors j'ai
rencontré à quelques années et on avait
parlé de vous magnéto serge qu'est ce
que tu préfères chez lui monsieur c'est
difficile parce que c'est un homme qui
a du tchador surtout tout le monde mais
il est cette norme le plus intelligent
que j'ai jamais je connais son
intelligence que tu préfères lui
ça c'est un des choses pas mal non plus
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus sexy
mais tous les deux je veux dire
écouter tous les gens sont très très
sexy
j'adore son corps oui c'est bien ça va
enlever sur un torse nu quand
est ce que tu aimes le moins
de lui et bah oui mais je tente plus
mauvais
il parle de prétentieux non je trouve
pas ça écoute ça c'est les journalistes
qui s il n'ya pas prendre potentielles
écoutes il est il est un homme très
intelligent
en plus il a une visage et le jeu est
très beau il est très fier ce qui ça non
je pense que le mot prétend siet homos
des journalistes qui sont vraiment
jaloux donné
tu lèves
au
souk you thought you
jeune homme
c'est rare dans le show business des
histoires d'amour qui dure aussi
longtemps
nous n'est pas comme chez nous et on et
maryvonne réponse bonnes réponses
il ya peut-être une dernière chose là
j'en parle à ma femme tout à l'heure
c'est la question colombo
[Musique]
alors quand je vous ai reçus dans tout
le monde en parle en 2004 il ya 15 ans
vous m'avez raconter une expérience
ayahuasca un psychotrope puissant que
vous aviez pris au brésil
et vous me parlez à l'époque de séismes
intérieur après cette expérience vous
vous étiez retrouver comme un soldat
britannique dans la bataille de la somme
en 1916
souviens très bien
deux jours après vous aviez un concert à
rio ou deux crans deux cent mille
personnes et vous aviez perdu quelques
mois auparavant vos parents est ce que
c'est la chose la plus difficile que
vous ayez eu à faire dans votre vie ce
concert
de perdre mes parents
vous savez on devient philosophe quant
aux blessés il faut apprendre cette
philosophie parce qu'on se rend compte
que pas notre tour va venir
j'espère pouvoir affronter la mort avec
courage avec sagesse et avec un humour
est-ce que depuis cette époque vous avez
eu l'occasion de reprendre de
l'ayahuasca hertz et oui et tu veux
disons que
c'est une expérience très éprouvante
une expérience difficile c'est une
espèce de médicaments qui vous force à
traiter de questions et qu'on a envie
d'éviter justement tels que la mortalité
telle qu'on a été une bonne paire
assis toi non ça va tu te souviens de
sting
sait même pas que je m'en souviens c'est
quand les stars internationales vous
fait un compliment
merveilleux on m'en a parlé depuis
depuis 15 ans il ya 15 ans dans tout le
monde en parle vous avez demandé ce que
vous aimeriez avoir comme qualité dans
la vie et vous aviez dit
l'intelligence de laurent peut-être lui
imposer cette phrase je pense pas que ce
soit naturel parce qu'il me connaissait
pas dix minutes mais ça m'a fait
tellement plaisir j'ai pu rentrer chez
moi j'ai renouer avec ma femme ça a été
cette petite phrase a été formé là pour
moi et je voulais le remercier encore
est-ce qu'on peut regarder et magnéto
serge quand vous vous regardez dans la
glace le matin vous vous dites quoi
je vois mon père de plus en plus et je
dis quoi ton père dans la glace
je dis que je sais que tu es mort dit
non je suis pas morte vous changeriez
quoi en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique
pour moins d'argent peut-être
à gauche à radio web j'aimerais bien
avoir votre esprit assez gentil les
corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux